welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in the mandalorian on Disney plus
we'll return for a second season or if
you live outside the US a first season
when you finally get Disney Plus in
March
I'm sorry Disney hates you but we've
uncovered some new details pointed out
how the second season will address the
show's lingering mystery spoiler warning
for the mandalorian the cryptic
backstory of Moff gideon and how we got
the dark saber baby otis species and
what they want to do with him the
mystery Tatooine figure in Chapter five
and what horrible things happen to the
Mandalorian race excuse me
creed and thanks to privacy at our
conference sponsoring this episode you
can sign up now have privacy icon slash
new rock stars you can get $5 today to
use on any purchase online okay let's go
through each of these Mandalorian
mysteries to explain what new details we
have learned and where they're gonna go
in season 2
starting with Mothe Gideon and the dark
saber in my breakdown of the finale
episode I went into some detail about
the dark sabers history with the people
of Mandalore as the ancient saber of
tarah Vizsla the first Mandalorian Jedi
and how its traded hands over the years
from the Vizsla family to maul and
eventually this Sabine Wren and Bo Catan
and rebels this is around the year to
BBY the family episode gave us some
backstory of Moff Gideon Moff Gideon was
an isp officer during the purge
so is be refers to Imperial Security
Bureau essentially the SS of the empire
military interrogators who snuff out
disloyalty in the ranks so as an
authority known to mando Moff Gideon may
have led this purge to raid Mandalorian
best scar and weaponry including their
sacred sword this purge would have
happened sometime between two BBY this
was two years before the rebels steal
the Death Star plans and blow it up and
for ABY when the Empire began to
collapse following the Battle of Endor
Giancarlo Esposito confirmed in an
interview that season two would explore
more of his character so I assume next
season will feature flashbacks to
sometime during that six to seven year
period in which moth Gideon himself
plunders the most precious artifact to
the Mandalorian people the dark saber
perhaps even crying it from the cold
dead fingers of poket on and using this
weapon to instill fear and discipline
within his stormtrooper unit even after
the broader imperial apparatus collapses
but what does Mothe Gideon want with the
child our Lord and Savior baby Jesus
Yoda we still don't know much about this
little meme Verna Herzog's client
character one in baby Yoda captured dead
or alive suggesting his boss Moff Gideon
didn't really care if the child died
either but they did want to extract
something from him dr. Pershing was
using an imperial interrogator droid
with a syringe either to inject or
extract something from this child
Pershing claimed to want to protect the
child to care about its safety and to
understand its greater significance if
uniform featured a patch with a signet
matching the logo of the clones of
Kamino suggesting an origin in genetic
engineering but later in the season
Quayle shot down that theory I think it
might be a strand cast I don't think it
was engineered I've worked in the gene
farms this one I think we could take pig
Nolte at his word perhaps maybe Yoda was
a natural-born life form of its species
but these imperial forces still wanted
to extract his DNA so that they could
head back to Kamino to clone him to make
an army of force-sensitive Yoda's for
the dark side it appears that season two
will further explore baby Otis origin
and species as mando seeks his home
planet a mystery that Star Wars Canon
has never really elaborated on
previously expected to search the galaxy
for the home of this creature and
deliver it to a race of enemy sorcerers
this is the way but equally murky is the
unfilled gap period in Mandalorian
history in which our hero emerged before
continue I just want to say that hey I
feel your pain at the now endless number
of streaming services you have to stay
subscribe to even though ones like
Disney Plus only offers seasonal content
and I'm kind of okay with unsub in
between now and season two the
Mandalorian but that's why privacy calm
has been such a godsend to me and by the
way thanks to privacy icon for
sponsoring this episode
privacy lets you pay for things online
using virtual burner cards instead of
your real credit cards that way you can
protect your identity and banking
information when you're shopping online
but also you can control the limits on
those burner cards so for example I've
set up an account with privacy and I've
linked my bank account created a card
specifically for my monthly Netflix
subscription payment so privacy will
ding you with lightning-fast precision
if someone tries to charge the card
twice or the
charge exceeds the amount you set for it
so like in a few months when your
favorite show leaves Netflix you won't
accidentally be stuck paying for another
month of fuller house that you don't
want no vendor can overcharge beyond the
limit that you have set it is simple
it's fast it's really just one click
they also offer different plans like
there's a free plan that lets you create
up to 12 cards a month which is great
there's also a pro plan where you can
get 36 cards a month and 1% cash back on
purchases and it seems plan for small
businesses they got something for
everyone and now there's a privacy
Chrome extension where you can fill out
all of your card info to save time one
click and all your details are instantly
entered just head to privacy comm slash
new rockstars and sign up for an account
and as a special treat for my viewers
new customers will automatically get
five dollars to spend on your first
purchase for a limited time only
yep that's three money folks just go to
privacy icon slash new rock stars and
sign up now okay back to the mystery of
meeeeee and Oh in the death watch the
finale episode revealed mandos name vin
Joran and the people who rescued him
from the separatist conflict a group of
blue armored Mandalorians with this
three-pronged Signet this is the signet
of the Death Watch originally introduced
as a terrorist warrior clan of
Mandalorians from the Clone Wars
animated series who at first challenged
the authority of their pacifist leader
during the Clone Wars conflict in order
to try to spur their people to reimburse
their warrior ancestry and join this
conflict they form an alliance with Maul
and after that backfires years later
they kind of become a heroic rebel group
rallying against Imperial occupation in
some are speculating that that female
leader of mandos tribe on Navaro the
armor could be an older boca tan though
her helmet designs stems from the Maul
era of the Death Watch
so I don't know if that's true but one
of those tribe members was named Paz
Vizsla and was voiced by Jon Favreau who
also voiced the death watch leader Pre
Vizsla in the Clone Wars series so I'm
assuming the season two will reveal that
this tribe that we find manda with was
the remnants of that Death Watch post
purge Favreau was really the reason we
know what second seasons come in thanks
to his Instagram post revealing art of a
gomorian those pig nose creatures who
guarded Jabba's palace on Tatooine and
returned the Jedi and a return to
tattooing brings of our final big
mystery which came up in season one
statue in episode chapter 5 the
gunslinger in which Amanda joins Toro
Callahan who track
Phenix and who left4dead is found in the
episodes final seconds by a mystery
figure in Boots
in a cape so who is this
though not confirmed all signs point to
our man Boba Fett's who was last seen
falling into the Sarlacc pit on Tatooine
in Return of the Jedi there have been
various hints over the years and several
Star Wars supporting material that Boba
Fett actually survived that Sarlacc but
this has not yet been firmly established
as canon Jon Favreau and Dave Bologna
said way back when that Boba Fett would
not be in season 1 but you know you
could interpret that to mean anything
above the knees beyond the Tatooine
setting there are two audio clues from
that chapter 5 final scene that point to
Boba Fett listen closely
okay first you can hear what sounds like
Spurs on each of those figure steps
which matches the sound of the Spurs on
Boba Fett's boots in the Empire Strikes
Back also as the figure approaches he
can hear some beeping sound this is very
similar to the beeping that you could
hear on Boba Fett and be a new hope
special edition added scene with Jabba
and Han the deadline report of season 2
cited insiders hinting that several
established characters from the
Skywalker saga showing up in the next
season and with the return of the
gomorian whom we last saw on Tatooine I
think there's a very good chance that
mando returns to that planet and runs
into that bounty hunter who made
Mandalorian armor so famous to us what
are your predictions for the Mandalorian
season to comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at a vas following the rockstars
on social media and subscribe to new
rockstars here on youtube and check out
our new Q&A series the big question
fulfilled when I get a little drunk and
give you way too much information about
Palpatine sexual history lots of other
fun questions it's actually become my
favorite thing that we do here at new
rockstars so please watch and share it
around with your friends thank you for
watching bye
[Music]